사상의 선형 결합이 주어진 입력에서 어떻게 정의되는지는, 출력의 같은 선형 결합을 취하면 돼요.
이건 좀 사소해 보일 수 있지만 말이 돼요. 이 가상의 시나리오에서 얻는 출력은 단순히
두 원래 채널에서 얻을 출력의 가중 평균이에요. 그럼에도 이건 새로운 채널이고,
Φ_0와 Φ_1이 유효한 채널이었다면, 이 새로운 사상도 확실히 유효한 채널이 될 거예요. 이걸 수학적으로
다르게 말하면, 주어진 입력 시스템에서 주어진 출력 시스템으로의 모든 채널의 집합은
볼록이라는 거예요. 이건 채널의 중요한 수학적 특성이에요. M개의 채널 Φ_0부터 Φ_이 있으면 더 일반적으로 할 수 있어요.
각 채널에 대한 확률을 알려주는 확률 벡터와 함께라면, 채널들을 그에 따라 평균해서 새로운 채널을 얻을 수 있어요.
어떤 의미에서 이건 새로운 채널의 무한한 원천이에요. 예를 들어, 소위 혼합 unitary 채널이라는 것은
unitary 채널의 볼록 결합을 취해서 얻는 거예요. 즉, 같은 크기의 M개의 unitary 행렬 U_0부터 U_이 있고
확률 벡터와 함께라면, 개별 unitary 행렬들에 대응하는 채널들의 가중 평균을 취하면,
화면에서 보이는 것처럼, 채널을 얻을 수 있어요. 그리고 이렇게 쓸 수 있는 채널들을
혼합 unitary 채널이라고 불러요. 모든 채널이 혼합 unitary 채널인 건 아니에요.
이 방법으로 모든 채널을 얻을 수는 없지만, 꽤 자주 등장해요. 다음으로 채널의 몇 가지 구체적인
예시를 살펴볼게요. 이것들은 모두 하나의 qubit에서 하나의 qubit로의 채널 예시인데, 줄여서 qubit
채널이라고 불러요. 첫 번째는 qubit 리셋 채널이라고 불리고, 이 채널은 qubit을
영 상태로 리셋해요. 여기서 그리스 대문자 Lambda를 이 채널을 나타내는 데 써요. 이 채널이 무엇을 하는지 기억하는 방법은
블로흐 구를 생각해 보는 거예요. 대문자 Lambda는 위를 가리키는 화살표처럼 보이고, 영 상태는 블로흐 구의 꼭대기에 있어요. 마치
출력의 위치를 가리키는 것 같아요. 수학적으로는 Lambda(ρ) = Tr(ρ)|0⟩⟨0|로 정의돼요.
임의의 밀도 행렬 ρ에 적용하면 밀도 행렬로서의 영 상태를 얻어요. 왜 대각합이 필요한지 궁금해지는 건 자연스러워요.
Lambda(ρ)를 앞에 Tr(ρ) 없이 그냥 |0⟩⟨0|로 정의할 수는 없는 건가요?
그 질문의 답은 '아니오'예요. 채널은 선형 사상이어야 하는데, Tr(ρ)를 제거하면 선형이 되지 않아요. 또한 때로는
밀도 행렬이 아닌 입력에 대한 선형 사상으로서 채널이 어떻게 작동하는지 알아야 한다는 것도 기억하세요.
예를 들어, 앞서 봤듯이 복합 시스템에 채널을 적용할 때 어떻게 되는지 알려면,
더 큰 블록 행렬의 개별 블록들에 그 채널을 적용해야 해요. 전체 블록 행렬이
밀도 행렬일 수 있더라도, 개별 블록들은 일반적으로 밀도 행렬이 아니에요. 이 채널을 복합 시스템의 한 부분에만
적용하면 정확히 어떻게 되는지, 더 구체적으로는 ebit을 형성하는 두 qubit 중 하나에 적용하면
어떻게 되는지 살펴볼게요. 정확히 말하면, A와 B가 쌍으로 Φ+ Bell 상태에 있는 qubit들이고, Lambda를
첫 번째 qubit A에 적용한다고 가정해요. 어떻게 되는지 알아보기 위해, 먼저 Φ+ 상태를 밀도 행렬로 표현하고,
이 예시를 위해 직접 표기법을 써서 해볼게요. 여기 양자 상태 벡터로서의 Φ+ 상태가 있고, 이 벡터와 켤레 전치를 곱하고
모두 전개하면 이렇게 돼요. 그러면 첫 번째 qubit에 채널을 적용하고 결과를 계산할 수 있어요.
첫 번째 qubit에 Lambda를 적용한 결과예요. 각 항을 계산하면, Tr(|0⟩⟨0|)=1이고
Tr(|1⟩⟨1|)=1이에요. 그래서 이 두 경우에 채널의 출력은 |0⟩⟨0|이고, 이게 답의
두 항을 설명해요. 반면 Tr(|0⟩⟨1|)=0이고 Tr(|1⟩⟨0|)=0이에요.
그래서 그 두 항은 0으로 계산되고, 따라서 답에 아무런 기여도 하지 않아요.
이제 조금 단순화하면, 첫 번째 qubit A에 대한 영 상태와
두 번째 qubit B에 대한 완전 혼합 상태를 얻어요. 특히 B에 대해 + 상태를 얻지 않는다는 점에 주목하세요.
밀도 행렬에 대해 아무것도 모르고 상태의 양자 상태 벡터 표현만 봤다면, 그게 그럴듯한 추측이었을 수 있어요. 하지만 그건
이 채널의 작동 방식이 아니고, 이렇게 작동할 수 있는 채널은 없어요. 채널 Lambda는 qubit 리셋 채널이라고 불리지만,
실제 작동 방식은 입력 qubit을 버리고 영 상태의 새로운 qubit으로 교체하는 것에 가까워요. 실제로 이건
항상 영 상태를 출력하는 유일한 qubit 채널이에요. 여기 qubit 채널의 또 다른 예시가 있는데,
완전 위상 제거 채널이라고 알려진 거예요. 이건 Delta로 표시되고, 작동 방식은 임의의 2x2 행렬의 대각
항목들을 그대로 두고 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만드는 거예요. Delta는 라틴 알파벳의 D에 해당하는 그리스 문자이고,
이는 대각(diagonal)의 약자예요. 그래서 이 채널이 무엇을 하는지 기억하는 한 가지 방법이에요.
화면에서 보이는 것처럼 직접 표기법을 사용해서 이 채널을 대안적으로 표현할 수도 있어요. 명확히 말하면, 출력은
항상 2x2 행렬이에요. 그래서 특히 두 개의 영 출력은 전부 영인 2x2 행렬을 가리켜요. 이런 걸
자주 하는데, 이 시리즈에서 전에도 봤어요. 기호 0은 일반적으로 어떤 것을 다루든, 스칼라든 벡터든 행렬이든, 그 것의 영 원소를
의미하는 데 약간 모호하게 쓰여요. qubit 리셋 채널에서 했던 것과 같은 걸 해봐요.
이 채널을 ebit의 절반에 적용하면 어떻게 되는지 봐요. 설정은 같으니 그 부분은 넘어갈게요.
결과는 화면에 표시된 상태인데, 이건 본질적으로 공유 랜덤 비트예요. 이 채널이 한 건
기본적으로 ebit을 완벽하게 상관된 고전적 랜덤 비트 쌍으로 변환한 거예요.
이는 이 채널의 더 일반적인 해석과 일치해요. 밀도 행렬의 비대각 항목들을 0으로 만듦으로써, 효과적으로
밀도 행렬에서 양자적인 부분을 버리고, 고전적 확률 상태를 나타내는 대각 밀도 행렬을 남겨요.
이걸 생각하는 또 다른 방법은 이 채널이 비트를 전송하는 완벽한 잡음 없는 고전적 채널을 나타낸다는 거예요.
영 상태나 일 상태 또는 그 두 상태의 볼록 결합을 채널에 넣으면, 그 상태가 변하지 않고 나와요. 하지만 + 상태 같은
양자 상태를 넣으려고 하면, 마치 채널이 표준 기저 측정으로 그 상태를 측정하고
고전적 결과를 전송하는 것처럼 돼요. qubit 채널의 마지막 예시는 완전 편극 제거 채널이에요.
이 채널이 하는 건 항상 완전 혼합 상태를 출력하는 거예요. 어떤 의미에서 qubit 리셋 채널과 비슷하지만,
초기화된 qubit 대신 그다지 유용하지 않은 완전 혼합 상태가 나와요. 이 채널을 생각하는 자연스러운 방법은
극단적인 형태의 노이즈를 나타낸다는 거예요. qubit 채널에 관한 한, 이것보다 더 잡음이 많을 수는 없어요.
이게 무엇을 하는지 기억하기 위한 좋은 기억법은 없는데, Omega가 그리스 알파벳의 마지막
문자이고 때로 모든 것의 끝과 연결된다는 것 외에는요. 어쩌면 이게 여기서 일어나는 일일 수도 있어요.